Crime Boss Rocket City seems to be
trying to fill a payday-sized void I'm
not sure exists Payday 2 will be a
decade old this August but it's still
getting new content in 2023 with the
latest expansion hostile takeover Heist
releasing in February 2023 much like the
payday games Crime Boss is a co-op first
person shooter where groups of four
tackle heists and have to mow down waves
of cops whenever things go wrong unlike
those games however Crime Boss doesn't
seem to offer as much freedom in how you
plan a heist it makes for a not very
engaging experience though I'm hopeful
the story driven campaign rectifies that
shortcoming with its roguelite
Inspirations developed by in-game
Studios and published by 505 games Crime
Boss is an organized crime game you can
play solo with Bots or in a group of up
to four part of the start of a mission
you select your team of four from a
roster of several characters each with
their own skills expertise and weapon
Loadout there is some customization in
terms of gadgets you can switch out a
collection of guard distracting rocks
Forex explosive frag grenades or
information gathering scanner grenades
for example but the characters
themselves cannot be altered you work
with the pros and cons you got at a
preview event I got to play about an
hour of the game's urban legends mode in
which a group of four tackle small
three-part stories the first thing I
noticed about the mode was a lack of a
planning stage which felt like an odd
Omission there are no maps to pour over
security cameras back into or Intel to
discuss with your team each Mission does
feature a briefing during character
selection but they're not very
informative Beyond detailing what task
you're attempting to do whether that's
stealing bags of cocaine from a yacht or
shooting your way across a bridge this
pushes every Heist away from stealth
even if the voice talking to you via the
radio in your ear suggests is the ideal
way to approach the mission it's
difficult to sneak your way through a
level without a little bit of Recon to
inform your decision this might have
been alleviated if there was a way to
scout a level once you're in the thick
of it but I didn't see a way to enemies
and Crime Boss are also unreasonably
observant they spot you quite easily and
once they do every enemy in the area
somehow knows the exact location of
every person on your team removing any
chance to return to stealth One South is
broken the game transitions into a
frantic first person shooter we have to
shoot dozens of cops that swarm the area
in seconds hauling whatever you've
managed to steal back to your Escape
vehicle again if you've played Payday 2
you're familiar with this formula it's
the same practically beat for beat the
big difference is that Payday 2 affords
you more opportunities to plan prior to
the start of a heist and then find
numerous ways to gather additional
information once the mission is underway
and Payday 2 abandoning stealth and
going guns blazing is an option and
Crime Boss or at least urban legends
specifically it feels more like a
necessity every Mission I played
resulted in a shootout with the cops
which is Fun the first two or three
times but after six or seven missions in
a row begins to feel repetitive the game
doesn't do a very good job encouraging
players towards stealth either given how
easy it is kill the cops the challenge
they present is found in numbers more
than anything else begging the question
as to why my team should even bother
committing to stealth sure the game
feels samey if you don't try to mix
things up with self there's no
punishment for messing up and just
finishing the assignment in A Storm of
gunfire I'm hoping Crime Boss is single
player campaign Baker's battle is a lot
better while I didn't get a chance to
try it I wish you in a video of what
that story mode will look like in it you
play as wannabe Crime Boss Travis Baker
whose quest to overtake Rock a city is
opposed by Rebel gang bosses and the
self-righteous and sword-wielding
Sheriff Norris Travis has a little help
though right hand man nasara gang crew
Captain touchdown love interest Casey
and dirty cop gloves there is a stacked
cast of talent voicing and providing
mocap in crime boss's story but at the
handful of scenes I saw in urban legends
are any indication they're working with
a script that isn't all that compelling
the far more intriguing element of the
story mode is in how it will apparently
evolve depending on how you tackle
missions the preview video said that
sheriff Norris were respond to your
actions coming at you harder if you
leave incriminating evidence against
Travis in earlier levels once Norris
catches or kills you it's game over and
you'll have to start the whole campaign
over borrowing from roguelike games your
next run through the campaign will
apparently be slightly different however
levels you've played before will feature
altered layouts and events on the story
will play out differently but any
permanent perks you've unlocked in
previous runs will carry over and
hopefully allow you to get a little
further than you did previously Baker's
battle sounds very cool and if the
writing is better than what's in urban
legends I think that's where Crime Boss
can most differentiate itself from
Payday 2 and stand out as a compelling
organized crime first person shooter to
keep on top of Crime Boss and other
upcoming first person shooters be sure
to stay subscribed to GameSpot